hey I'm Peter Ruben I'm Kelly ribbon
this is Crosby this is split screen
because we know there's always more than
one side to every story
at every TV show and every movie and
every game games like Mortal Kombat 10
or X 10 really tempt I think it is the
10th but it's been like 23 years since
the game had first began as an arcade
cabinet in 92 oh my god it's crazy and
in this one something that's really
interesting is the good folks at Kotaku
went and checked out on the multiplayer
servers to see who's playing what cat
I'll bet I know number one so far and
away the most popular player more than
double almost everyone is scorpion yummy
come here get over here come here come
here and like why is that I don't know
but I grew up in a Tekken household and
scorpion really was the only character
that I knew from Mortal Kombat if I saw
him I'm like there it is but even part
of it is definitely yeah he's the he's
the face of the game he's got that
catchphrase that we don't know right now
and he does that thing with that thing
but Sub Zero was basically scorpion yeah
he's like scorpion in a blue suit though
but the fact the fact that scorpion is
being played more than twice as often as
like Raiden he's a favorite character of
mine he's pretty cool so I guess the
question is why do people choose the
characters they play that is a good
question because I went in and I was
like oh look there's a black woman
character let me go play her and she was
the worst so to be over to be fair
that's Jax's daughter Jackie Briggs
that's great ISM game but still and
she's just boring she's just look
there's all the sexual colors as
military people are always super boring
immortal commits you want to play the
the monsters and the mystic that's what
I'm saying that's the truth hey go I do
oh yeah you're right so I'm sorry that
the black woman character is not a
freakish she's like scar mouth
mask-wearing and we complain about that
too yeah that's what I'm saying and so I
think the difference for me too is that
fighting games I want to play
whoever's got the best fatality or the
best move yes because I do like watching
it's not like an RPG where you can make
a character who looks exactly like you
which I do basically every time yes you
make your exec you every time you take
great pains wizard version head shape no
shape just all of it and I call you in
I'm like is that right and you're always
like make it uglier that's our version
where we'll combat you're sick burn
fatality carrier
yes barrier well no come back from that
I've been fatality but we'll be back we
will next week next week and we hope
you'll join us on another split-screen